GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY NINTH IS HEREBY
COLD ORDER. UP USUALLY ADVISE AN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S FOR.
MADE.
TELEVISED.
AMENDED SECTOR PIECE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HIGH CUNNINGHAM HERE
ARE CHARGED PART OF ME HERE.
CUNNINGHAM
ALLEN
BOROUGH CARE.
CARILLO HERE TORONTO JUST
FRIEDMAN.
GRAYSON HERE.
THOSE AREA.
SOLACE PRESIDENT.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION THE
CONSENT AGENDA SECOND BOOMER
MUCH BRO SECONDED BY MISTER
GRAYSON AMAP SECTOR PRIESTS CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY HIGH COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM ALAN'S BROKE FIVE
BROUGH AYE KOREA AYE CORREO AYE
CERVANTES FRIEDMAN.
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE NAZARIAN
FIGHT.
IS THERE AND I SAW WEBSITE
SOLACE AYE WALDRON. WALDRON I
FINISHED.
VERY GOOD OF